well I have not caught as much crap from
my closest friends and relatives in a
long time and I haven't been made fun of
by my closest friends and closest
relatives to an unbelievable extent in
the past 18 hours I have gotten more
snarky smart-aleck emails from people
that loved me in the last 18 hours then
at any 18 hour period in my life why
because this nice young man at the
Washington Times named Ethan Epstein ran
an editorial suggesting that I should
run for president against Donald Trump
and people that know me best know how
really funny that is and how really a
bad idea that that is I would never do
that never in a million years do that
number one I have a much better job than
he does I control all the variables in
my life the level of hate I get is one
one Julian of a percent of what someone
gets in the White House and everybody
that I tell what to do around here does
it I run a benevolent dictatorship why
would I go up there and deal with those
people no thank you no thank you
that's just funny and it's it's a
variant and thank you young man that was
a very nice compliment that you would
think that I could add value to the
nation and I appreciate that but God's
call on me is very clear and it is to
sit on my butt right here on this
microphone and help America actually
help America which by the way the
president has hard time doing because of
the divisive nough sandy hate I have
gotten hate on Twitter and I didn't this
wasn't me that said this it's like you
gotta be kidding well it's okay guys
it's okay there's not a chance my cousin
who's an editorial cartoonist goes oh
please
the cartoons would be awesome but he's
the only one encouraged so let me just
help you guys that was cute and it was a
kind compliment and I appreciate that
but not a snowball's chance darlin not a
chance I'm doing exactly what I'm
supposed to be doing think about all the
people that miss out on their debt free
screams no no my life is good and the
last thing I'm gonna Papa Dave gets to
see his grandbabies every day why in the
world would I want to mess that up and
go up there so all you people half the
nation could hate me then I know thank
you
life is too short that's a crummy job
the pay's not that good and the crap you
put up with is endless
it's a horrible job who would want that
job oh you got to be weird to want it
now they're saying some of my friends
have wanted it and have really gone for
it and some of them are good men and
good women and I'm happy for them and
that's the world that they're called
into but man you'd have to I'd have to
get a telegram from God and no chance
all right but thank you Ethan Epstein
thank you you're very very kind and very
sweet of you but uh even called Mark
Cuban and suggested I run with it mark
and Mark said it was a good idea mark
you're not thinking man you have a good
life why would you wanna screw up your
life come on buddy all right all right
let's move on to something that's real